Hi there, what can I help
you with today?
Well, the other
day I was having trouble
making out this license
plate number
of a
particular school bus,
even though I was driving
very closely behind it
for a long
period of time.
In any case, what should
I do?
I think you
might like these.
These are our Church Basement
Computer Teacher Model.
But actually, you know what?
These are from
our Uncle Backrub line.
Yeah.
What a-- Now, do these make me
look like a serial killer?
I'll take 'em.
(chuckling)
Uh.
How can I help you?
Uh, I have a special
occasion coming up.
Oh, let me guess.
You and 120 of your
closest followers
are planning on drinking
poison from R.C. Cola cans?
It's not poison, it's
time juice.
Okay-- You know, why don't
you try these?
These might be perfect.
These are from our vintage
Koresh line.
They're perfect for going
straight from your compound
to burrito-ing yourself in a
wool blanket in the desert.
Sandy, would you like to
stroke my (bleep)?
Yeah, these are gonna
work great.
Oh, perfect, perfect.
I'm gonna check
out some other styles.
Please do.
Hi there.
Can I see how
you look in these?
Oh, no,
we have a strict policy
against trying on frames at
a customer's request.
Why?
Because you know why.
Oh, great, great.
But before I pay for them,
I just wanted to say
that I feel
very connected to you
and I sense that your heart
has many questions for me.
Uh, I've
got no questions,
but we appreciate your
business.
All right.
I take it I can pay for these
with jelly beans?
Okay.
There you are.
And you're sure there's
no questions?
I'm actually
gonna close up early.
I'm driving to my boyfriend's
house tonight.
Boyfriend--
All right, got it.
We'll just- You know, say
that first next time.
Okay?
Save us
both a lot of time.
Gonna learn from my
mistakes-- Thank you so much.
Great-- Yeah, that'd
be great if you did that.
And don't put out
such a vibe next time.
Okay.
(motor starting)
Brendan Fraser's house.
Lock and load.